[Music]
where was she
what was that
bro
oh she went through time like steve
i like this show
this is a good show
welcome back to new rock stars marvel
studios what if episode 1 asks what if
peggy carter received the super soldier
syrup to become captain carter but along
the way the episode introduces early
iron man tech possible variants with
peggy carter's blood
maybe and a trans-dimensional portal and
a squid monster
what what the
yeah
this is inside marvel our after show for
marvel's what if on disney plus i'm eric
voss here with mt hey what's going on
man dude captain carter went in she went
in on those mf's man i was gonna say the
bad words i'm not gonna say it she
pushed that demon back into hell i like
how in her mind she didn't know what was
on the other side of that portal she's
probably a god-fearing christian woman
just assumed she was going straight to
hell constantine style and didn't care
what a badass she was like i'll fight
the devil if i have to i got these
muscles man
i got a sword i got a shield what else
do i need right ah well in this episode
peggy carter's decision to stay in the
room where it happens leads to her
becoming a super soldier who leads the
allies to victory in world war ii
she steals the tesseract early howard
stark gets it and uses it to give skinny
steve the hydra stomper armor so he
still gets to be a badass awesome and uh
captain carter shoves a tentacled beast
back to hell missing her dance with
steve rogers and ends up in the future
future
the future or to us now the past that
was 2012 that was forever ago but so
much of this show is worthy of
discussion uh because what exactly was
this interdimensional monster how did
this portal just reveal a possible
threat to doctor strange in the upcoming
multiverse of madness how much of this
episode could affect the live-action
side of the mcu because mt you know the
producers at this show have been saying
this isn't just a corner of the mcu that
will never be revisited again they plan
to intertwine this [ __ ] into everything
they can in live action so the fact that
this opens with marvel studios tells us
this just because it's animated doesn't
mean that we can skip it this is
essential viewing this is probably going
to introduce some really big elements
that we're going to see in doctor
strange the multiverse of madness and
that spider-man movie that they're never
going to release a trailer for so we got
to be locked into this
and hey you know like the fact that it's
animated actually gets me even more
excited because they can do crazy stuff
in animation that they don't do in live
action anything like that gets to be
canon now it's like right this universe
is just becoming more and more very
interesting without anything and then we
could see that live action it's crazy
well if you haven't already checked out
our most recent latest obsession shirt
based on the suicide squad you really
need to head over to
newrockstarsmerch.com
that is a limited edition shirt and just
like captain boomerang spoiler warning
uh it's here for a good time but not a
long time all right uh and we're not
kidding about that the black widow lace
obsession shirt is already gone forever
like scarlett johansson herself from the
mcu so uh check out all of our great
merch options at drockstarsmirch.com and
keep an eye out because we got some new
releases maybe some what if inspired
designs dropping in the coming week
okay but empty what's our first question
coming out of this first episode of what
if eric what if the portal peggy carter
went through revealed the same
trans-dimensional threat dr strange will
face in his movie doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness like what was that
monster exactly yeah so other than uh
captain carter becoming the tip of the
spear as steve rogers was in the
original captain america movie uh which
by the way beautifully animated uh a lot
of great moments in this i'm excited to
see uh the next episode though maybe a
bit more with uh what if t'challa is
star-lord just because i love the
guardians of the galaxy side of the
universe the most i think uh just as a
cosmic mcu nerd um really the other
major alteration to the universe in this
alternate universe of the episode the
alternate
time strand or timeline or reality
whatever the logic of this is uh was the
way the tesseract switches hands kind of
like a nuclear football like carter
takes it earlier than it was taken in
the uh in the captain america movie it
allows howard stark to use it to power
the hydra stomper armor uh which kind of
seems like an early version of iron man
armor like right rather than designed by
howard stark's son designed by howard
stark himself and red skull by
kidnapping steve rogers uh uses the
tesseract to power not like weapons like
rifles cannons tanks and stuff but
really an early version of what project
pegasus would later do under eric selvig
to open a portal into the cosmos uh now
red skull in this episode is voiced by
ross marquand who actually took over the
role from hugo weaving in the avengers
infinity war and endgame just seems way
more obsessed than the character was in
the first cap film with the tesseract's
historical ties with the townsburg
church that engraved door of the
intracell world's tree and how the space
stone can do far more than help his
hydra armies conquer earth but really
how it can summon a hydra like champion
like mythological hydra from another
dimension and that monster has these
growing tentacles a mouth full of teeth
and you could say it looks like the
obelisk that attacked the sovereign
guardians galaxy vol 2. i think there's
some parallels there uh you remember
that old thing if federal knows any
likes batteries or quadrilary batteries
if you're drax uh and that was
specifically an interdimensional
creature but i think the contrasting
points though were that it was smaller
uh it seemed to have shorter tentacles i
would say there was more meat on the
bone of the body yeah and we don't
really see what's on the other side of
the limbs
we don't see the head attached to those
tentacles we just see the tentacles fall
off so it could be literally anyone yeah
like there's i think that there's a
definite link there because we do see an
inner dimension like the obelisk in the
guardians too is an interdimensional
creature they make a point to say that
so it'd be very weird for tentacle
creatures who are interdimensional to
not be related uh yeah i mean or to us
to our humanoid carbon bodies empty
anything that
isn't a bipedal creature seems weird but
you might be a bit discriminatory and
say that all tentacled beings are the
same wow um but i'm gonna put that on
the internet i'm tentacle racist all
right no head in time for me well
because they can't type their their
tentacles are too fat so yeah pounding
the
what's that game called is it octodad
this is game where you can play as like
an octopus dad and he's anyway sorry
that's random continue no continue i
want to hear more about octopus dad well
to me this beast mt looks more like the
great old ones okay the elder gods or
the many angled ones uh those have
appeared a few times in marvel comics
but recently in the 2009-2010 realm of
kings series it featured quasar
guardians the galaxy nova project
pegasus versus the reevengers
um now these are the giant tentacled
beans that were designed from the um
really from the influence of the cosmic
horror writer h.p lovecraft and his
entity nyarlathotep who uh i don't think
i ever pronounced correctly but yeah
they all have like hard to pronounce
names that if you ever said them right
would like melt your brain and make you
crazy um that's kind of his whole theme
i feel like if you said that three times
you would summon cthulhu yeah it was
also a great old one which is hilarious
whoops
um but one of the best known ones in uh
marvel lore is schumacher
and schuma gorath is rumored to appear
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
and i do agree with umt i think it's
pretty wild for the first episode of
what if to steer so hard into cosmic
horror and these big tentacled monsters
and i don't think the animators would
include just any uh anonymous
interdimensional squid monster in the
pilot of the series that marvel studios
is claiming so fiercely is going to be
setting up the marvel cinematic universe
and the multiverse is all going to be
connected and i don't think it was just
because it parallels the hydra beast of
mythology i think i think red skull
would underline that more and refer to
it as like literally you caught off one
had two heads uh form in its place it
would have been a headed monster as
opposed to these just being limbs right
you know uh so i think the fact that
peggy carter came out of the other side
of this portal 68 years later in the
future un-aged kind of like scott lang
coming out from the quantum realm
signals to us that this beast came from
a dimension beyond time and that's why
it's important to think a bit harder
than you really should about the nature
of reality on this show that it just
seems like this is just like a way of
explaining these twilight zone setups
right but really i think the idea is
that coming out of loki
we are splitting into these different
realities and there are these moments
these little miniature nexus points that
go unerased by the tva and just kind of
create these like what if hypotheticals
that maybe the fact that it's animated
means that it's lower priority to the
tva and it's able to slip under their
radar and still kind of exist in these
otherworldly forms uh and in between of
those timelines the fact that we see
a interdimensional portal within this
hypothetical timeline means that they
are slipping between timelines and
that's where i think we get dimensions
and realms i believe you have an episode
of a big question coming up that kind of
digs yes me and marina actually could
dive into this in our big question
episode because yeah we get into
dimensions realms ancestral plane it's
all very technical stuff it's it really
broke our brains while we were talking
about i'm very excited to see that and
when we talk about dimensions and realms
in the mcu i think we're talking about
like the worlds of doctor strange like
those dimensions are all kind of surreal
and abstract they look like lsd
paintings um
everything's melting and turning into
hands that's where this beast came from
kind of like the dark dimension right
right um and those are the worlds where
doctor strange definitely has some more
navigation experience so i don't know if
goreth in particular was this um
technical monster or will be the primary
villain of multiverse madness but i do
think
this beast and this what if episode and
others like it are highly likely to
appear in the next live-action doctor
strange film because let's be honest
they're going to be cgi characters
anyway yeah
either way it's gonna be animated just
what is it gonna be 2d or 3d oh yeah
doctor strange is the definite most
likely version or or place that we're
going to see
um a tentacle creature because the many
angled ones i and like schumer gorath in
particular were very much doctor strange
villains in doctor strange threats and
doctor strange is this warrior who goes
throughout dimensions and fights these
monsters so doctor strange is the most
likely event that we will see another
tentacled monster but i also believe
that we could see them appear in quantum
mania as well because quantomania with
ant-man and all them like we see an end
game that you can go through across
different timelines for the quantum
realm but also the reason why i think
this the most is because of the abylus
creature in guardians 2 because we
noticed that it already had a cut on its
neck before yeah that uh gamora used to
to kill it i think that we're going to
see
ant-man make that cut in quantum mania
and then we're gonna get some weird time
travel thing where it hops in and the
car getting the guardians finish it off
so i think that we're gonna see more of
mt you are going rogue my friend you are
off the rails oh and i love it don't you
ever dare get back on the rails oh never
the train is gone
now do you think it's possible that uh
you know because in loki we had this
background character that people were
saying looks like peggy carter and
specifically when the series director
was asked about that she didn't debunk
it she was like
keep thinking about that
do you think it's possible that we could
see a live-action captain carter cameo
in the background of multiverse of
madness with one of these squid monsters
flying through the cosmos and you just
see her floating like
like gandalf
in the minds of warrior yeah
yeah yo honestly i think that that is
highly likely because like why not why
not i mean i i don't think that's like
well
i think it's very likely that we could
see a uh captain carter appear in
multiverse of madness because like we're
gonna be hopping through multiverses
probably and you know we have um america
chavez on the team who is literally the
interdimensional hopper i just it just
seems likely marvel studios seems to be
all about captain carter right now they
do i think it'd be really great to for
for that little loki cameo to be
something in the future yeah i think uh
if live-action captain carter shows up
she's gonna have to show up in these
kind of multiversal settings because
they just introduced sam wilson as
captain america and i want him to be the
captain america on earth and nearby
earth you know uh maybe in like battle
world as well um i just want him to be
kind of the person carrying the shield
and then captain carter can just be some
kind of inter-dimensional variant who
works with like a captain britain core
or shows up in the background of these
weird uh other settings you know oh yeah
i definitely don't want captain carter
to be a mainstay in the marvel cinematic
live-action universe because we just got
like you said we just got sam wilson and
like the shield and him getting the
shield is so significant so to have two
variants of the shield running around
when sam just got the shield would be
kind of weird so yeah i agree with you i
think it would be really i mean her
shield is it's the union jack it's not
the stars and stripes we can have one in
britain one in america ah sure whatever
but
the shield itself is the fact that this
is badass shield that you could frisbee
around and you know it kind of makes you
one of a kind i only want one of those
on earth at a time and like in the fact
that she's a super soldier kind of like
because we sort of tried throughout the
entirety of falconer soldier to be like
you don't need super soldiers to be
captain america you just need to you
know to be a good person into you know
particles i have a heart of gold and so
like to have to just to do all that and
then you'd be like all right here's
another super soldier with a captain
america shield well captain uh vibranium
shield it's just like ah
maybe not yet yeah um but yes i would
love to see them team up in like a
secret wars maybe one time that'd be
dope yeah why not i mean look here's the
thing i do love hayley atwell i thought
she's great and uh agent carter i think
there is a place for her in live action
in the mcu
and
would she need to get bulked up would
she need to be like kind of you know
ruffalo hulked out
i don't think so i think she can get in
you know what the best shape she could
get in maybe wear a bit of suit with a
bit of muscle padding
and we're good to go uh i think she
could guess i mean if zachary levi can
do shazam and like big ass
shazam why not read
agreed uh we have some more questions
coming out of this episode but first if
you are a fan of new rockstars you
already know who stan lee is and huge
impact he's had on marvel comics and the
entertainment industry as a whole what
fewer fans know is that in the early
2000s stan lee was really struggling
financially he was on the verge of suing
marvel
the all-new season of the business
movers podcast explores how stan lee
changed the comic book industry and
saved his own career in the process on
each season of business movers you'll
hear how titans of industry rose from
the bottom rung of the corporate ladder
and what obstacles they overcame on
their climb to the top i'm excited for
this podcast and more people to know
about this often forgotten era of stan
lee's life on business movers you'll
find out exactly how a kid from the
bronx born at the height of the great
depression went on to become a comic
industry superhero listen to the latest
episode of business movers stan lee on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen ad free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app wondering feel the
story
[Music]
or wondering feel the story if you
didn't want to listen to me sing i get
it we also want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode you don't want
to sleep on a mattress designed for
someone else even if it's an alternate
reality version of you that took the
super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers super soldiers still need good
sleep good well helix sleep has a quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz and i got
matched with the dusk luxe helix
mattress because i wanted a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support that sleeps
cool i sleep great on my helix mattress
way better than my evil variant twin
sleeps on his mattress do i need to
tighten those chains okay keep it down
the mattress ships right to your door
for free you never need to go to a
mattress store again they were awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq in wired magazine so
just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
audience at helixsleep.com inside marvel
that's helix sleep dot com slash inside
marvel for up to 200 off and two free
pillows all right mt there is this
moment from this episode that i know you
noticed what if peggy carter's blood
samples that they took from her could be
used to make future super soldier
experiments like red hulk or maybe
she-hulk in this reality yo that'd be
kind of crazy like but yo think about it
cause like because like in the comics
though the project that made wolverine
um was based off of the captain america
super soldier experiment so what if we
get like a female version of deadpool
baby because deadpool was one of those
um so like that'd be crazy if we got
like a gwen pool from this oh my god
they should totally do that like make
red pool from some even though
grenfell's origins are completely
different but like some type of like
either a deadpool or like something more
serious like a she-hulk like you said um
like that'd be
pretty crazy if they've got a what-if
story yeah i to me the context of that
moment with colonel flynn was like he
was kind of admonishing her in that
moment and he's like this is a mistake
that you became a super soldier so i'm
going to take your blood hopefully we
can um you know save this botched
operation whereas with steve rogers they
were all they considered as like mission
successful so i don't know if like we
saw they were running tests on them and
everything but you didn't see like them
taking a bunch of vials and then a
close-up on vials of his blood like it
seemed like he worked for them in world
war ii he went to the ice they kind of
lost a lot of that research uh but then
they were trying to you know resurrect
it with projects like you know hydro was
doing the winter soldier program uh and
then they had everything they were doing
with isaiah bradley and then uh thaddeus
ross
did it and that's how we got hulk bruce
banner turn into hulk uh so i wonder if
like now in this alternate reality they
have a lot more variation in what they
can do throughout the cold war despite
peggy carter disappearing through the
portal and then showing up in 2012 i
presume later um there could have been
all kinds of other super soldiers in all
types of forms uh and i think at first
you would you'd see more of john
walker's you know throughout the 50s and
60s i would have to assume see now that
you bring up john walker i was thinking
about this like
what if they actually just bring in john
walker for season two and like have a
captain carter versus john walker where
john walker has the full true super
soldier serum from like from peggy's
blood like from that example so like
would they just give it to john walker
because john walker is that white man
and so like there would still be that
struggle because like white women or
women in general are still you know
having to fight for equality against
white men and they're still being
discriminated so like having john walker
be [ __ ] again for uh for a captain
carter fight would be uh would be quite
interesting because uh that would be
interesting for sure and i think like i
mentioned red hulk we it's hard to
imagine how red hole could exist in the
live-action mcu i think it's doable i
think it will happen in our lifetimes
but i think like what if is a perfect
place to test out red hulk because it's
just like the simple version of that
it's just like what if hulk instead of
green was red and i think for a lot of
kid comic readers that's really all it
really meant to them so to just show
that variation in animation i think is
such like an easy sell
and i would hope that you know assuming
that based off a trailer footage i think
captain carter is going to return in the
series we see her talking to doctor
strange in the trailer right so like
maybe
red hulk could be
the consequence of her blood being taken
from her or
or since we're on the hulk what about
the leader bro we can't forget about the
leader yeah so like i feel like later
the leader could be like probably
working on these experiments because
he's all about that gamma stuff so like
maybe we'll see the leader and what if
that'd be dope in terms of like other
things that were left behind by this
episode what if steve rogers lives on as
an early era iron man in the 40s 50s and
60s because he was left behind with
peggy carter she was left behind worked
with shield you know but now steve
rogers is kind of like this era's war
machine at least you know he's this guy
who's got this powered suit you got to
imagine howard stark's going to want to
build on that and hydro stomper was a
craze you know that's not going to end
so what's next for skinny steve i have a
feeling that you know skinny steve like
after hydra stopping he probably became
president like i think that'd be like
the next step for for steve rogers like
you know what's certainly a celebrity
yeah he's like he comes back for the war
he's like yeah i just like messed up all
these nazis and like you know i'm a
poster boy even though i'm kind of
skinny like i can't do the war all the
time i'ma be the president i think that
having him as this early era iron man
with howard stark it would sort of like
completely change the the course of
howard stark's life because does he even
go become a weapons manufacturer at this
point like does he become an iron man
suit manufacturer do him and steve
rogers work together and like do sort of
that like i don't know like there's so
many i think that's the idea of it like
i think howard stark unlike his son uh
in this episode he's like i only want to
push the buttons like he's afraid to go
into an armed conflict whereas tony
stark at least after you know being
kidnapped by the tin rings in raza's
group uh he's certainly okay with
putting on the suit himself he doesn't
trust other people to wear the suit and
that's different from howard stark he
trusts steve rogers to do it so like i
would love to see that partnership
throughout the decades and see how it
evolves how it changes do they have a
falling out uh does steve rogers have a
falling out with the government the way
tony stark and iron man 2 did not want
to give the government his uh his
armor his technology until he forged
that friendship with brody so i that's a
whole fascinating history i'd love to
see and and we still have hydra you know
lurking in the background of shield so
like
that's a whole like imagine like the
winners sola is still alive if operation
paperclip still happens then zola is
certainly in a position to continue to
corrupt shields there's so many
different things that could happen just
from this timeline alone yes
i was so hyped to see him i was like yes
i really hope that they like by the end
of this like that zola like real zola
comes to the mcu
um yeah and and then dies and then
becomes
the people
yes modok please we have to get modoc
soon please marvel well a couple more
people we want to thank our friends at
upstart for sponsoring this episode if
you dread looking at your credit card
statement every month upstart can help
lift that weight off your shoulders
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart looks at more than
just your credit score like your income
your employment history this means they
can offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com marvel we also want to thank
feels for sponsoring this episode cbd
isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel stress anxiety pain
and other things that make you feel bad
well feels is the better way to feel
better feels is a premium cbd that helps
keep your head clear and feel your best
it's hassle free and delivered directly
to your door become a member and get 50
percent off your first order cbd
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness there's no
hangover or addiction i've used cbd in
the past to help with aches and pains
and a bunch of us here at new rockstars
are big fans of cbd place a few drops of
fields under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes fields offers
a free cbd hotline and a customer
service team to help you find your
perfect dose joining feels monthly
membership makes your self-care easy
save money on every order pause or
cancel anytime start feeling better with
feels become a member today by going to
peels.com marvel and you'll get 50 off
your first order with free shipping
that's f f-e-a-l-s dot com slash marvel
to become a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping fields.com marvel all
right empty
what if peggy carter continues to exist
in the present like the mcu steve rogers
did after got thought out of ice do you
think captain carter will return in an
episode later this season and what would
that story be do you think yeah so
that's definitely likely we're
definitely going to be seeing her later
on this this season as you know as we've
heard it from you know headlines that
captain carter is going to be you know a
mainstay for the what-if story like
she's going to be um in for season one
and for season two at the very least so
it would be weird if we didn't see her
in another episode this season it'd be
very very strange um and i i think it
would be really dope to see you know
some of those scenarios that we were
talking about earlier play out in a
future episode of with uh captain carter
in just to see how that universe um has
changed so much since now that we have
you know howard stark you know making
iron man suits and like we have
steve rogers as this hero and we have a
world without zola um you know
you know sort of being a main player
from the hydra days and i got so many
things have changed so like you know i
would really like to see
just how much that nexus event
changed everything in the modern day
yeah i mean clearly the producers on the
show see peggy carter as kind of the
focal character of the series you know
like i think she's uh already confirmed
to come back an episode for season two
uh which is just interesting since it
seems like an anthology show that they
want to revisit characters and follow
them on that journey so they're kind of
they're walking that line between the
two uh and yeah i i think we will see a
return this season uh or just like
further implications of things that have
happened in this episode uh i don't
think we're done with the hit with this
alternate history as we look ahead to
the remaining episodes of this season we
already know a good amount uh mt and i
did a preview episode last week where we
know that episode two is going to be
what if t'challa was star-lord uh
episode three is gonna be something
around fury's big week uh with like the
events of thor and iron man 2. um and
then uh beyond that we know there's a
marvel zombies episode we know there's a
doctor strange episode we know
spider-man is going to appear in an
episode um but
what do you think is going to be the big
standout moment from this season i know
every episode's gonna have a bit of that
but like what's gonna be do we think
there will be a post-credits scene
to this season that sets it up
like direct implications from things
that we saw in the show to live-action
parts of the mcu man it would be nuts if
we got like the fantastic four or like
some type of hinting towards the
fantastic four because we don't know
where they're at we have no idea where
they're at and so it would be crazy if
we got like uh either like a tease of
like you know fantastic four ship or
like uh you know the logo somewhere or
like it's like oh they were here like
like like there were astronauts who left
behind you know like little pieces of
evidence that they were there in
different multiverses i think that would
be nuts if they did that um but it more
realistically i think that you know
it's it's those ties to maybe
potentially loki that they could um you
know
introduce with like maybe a kang cameo
in uh in what if because we know that
kings are coming and they're infecting
the multiverse with their jonathan
majors charm
um yeah that's what i was thinking too
like what if we have a post-credits
scene where we stick with uh uwatu right
and we have his silhouette form in space
but then
that
shifts into
actually live-action jeffrey wright
sitting in the citadel with he who
remains
just kind of like making some
negotiations that'd be crazy what
timelines he gets to save and what
timelines are going to be ruptured and
then
uh uwatu goes thanks and he
disappears into the stars and then uh he
remains looks out the window and loki
and sylvia are walking up
that would be crazy if it was like a
weird pre oh my god that'd be nuts if he
just had a casual relate because they do
because a watcher didn't have a casual
relationship with the tva and the comics
so it would make sense if there was
there's precedent for that that's i love
that that's a really great idea i mean i
would just love to see
uh jonathan majors and jeffrey wright
share a scene together they're both
amazing actors and they're both playing
similar roles now for the ruby verse you
know just stalkers
also i want jonathan majors to show up
in everything just in little different
roles playing slightly different
characters different people i'm telling
you we gotta do norbit like jonathan
majors needs to have like a 20 picture
deal where he just puts on his various
suits and like just different things
like that'd be hilarious
[Laughter]
jonathan major's cameo in every movie
please
uh well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i are gonna be back
next wednesday with our what if episode
two reaction and coming up next on the
channel is my easter egg breakdown of
all the cool little there's awesome
animation details that i was able to
find uh especially when you compare it
with uh scenes in captain america the
first avenger so be sure to stay tuned
for that you guys are gonna love it um
and don't forget to check out our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
so much cool stuff you can do that
supports our channel directly when you
get that stuff follow me at eavos on
social media follow mt mastertainment
follow new rockstars subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching and we will close
with our favorite moment of the episode
[Music]
[Music]
you